(audience applauding)
- All right y'all.
We always like to end the show
with something you can feel good about.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
We've talked a lot here,
about little things
we can do to help save
this planet of ours.
And often there are small actions
that don't just protect the earth,
they actually can help people
living on it right now.
And LA Mama is proving
it with her organization,
Crayon Collection, people donate unused
or gently used crayons
keeping them out of
landfills, which is amazing.
Then they make their way to kids
who otherwise wouldn't have them.
It's pretty smart, right? And
that's just the beginning.
We have this mama of action
on the line right now.
Everybody say hi to Sheila who watches
on NBC for Los Angeles. Hi Sheila.
- Hi Kelly.
Thanks so much for having me today.
- Absolutely. Well, tell us more about
the Crayon Collection.
- The Crayon Collection is my
organization that I started
with my little toddler
daughter when she was
a super picky eater and we
kept going to restaurants.
She'd get a free four
pack of crayons each time
and sometimes she wouldn't
even use the crayons
but they'd still end up in the
trash at the end of the meal.
And this really drove me crazy
coz I knew so many kids need them
and the planet cannot take any
more trash in our landfills.
When I found out crayons
are thrown away at a
rate of 150 million per year
from restaurants in America,
I had to do something.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- So I started asking grass
restaurants to collect
the crayons kids leave
behind and I would find
a local school that was super vulnerable
also known as Title 1
schools to benefit from them.
Later on, we would go inside the classroom
with professional artists
with our art education program
and teach our really cool
art projects to reinsert that
into schools and it makes a huge impact.
We've done this for a while,
so we've donated over 22
million crayons to date.
- Wow.
- We have had hundred
thousand kids served.
We're in all 50 states, 10 countries.
And we even set a Guinness World Record
where we donated 1 million, 9,500 crayons
to over 900 teachers right
here in LA in one day.
(audience applauding)
- Oh my gosh.
It's an amazing thing coz
everything is being helped.
The planets being helped, the
landfills are being helped.
You know what I'm saying?
The kids are being helped.
Everyone kind of wins in this scenario.
It's a beautiful thing
that you've created.
I love also that it's not
about putting even more of a
carbon footprint out there.
You're actually like going local
like help the people that
live in your community.
That's so cool.
Thank you so much, Sheila.
I'm Liking your posts right now. Okay.
- [Sheila] Thank you so so much.
- Absolutely. And that's not all.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pen makers of Frixion,
the go to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
just like you ma'am, so
they're gonna give you
a thousand dollars to help out.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- Thank you. Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Absolutely
have a good one Sheila.